cette chaise paraît très actuel elle a
pourtant été conçu en 1928 voici sa
créatrice charlotte perriand mois la
tradition c'est de construire notre
porte
l'architecte et designer charlotte
perriand à définir nouvel art de vivre
tout au long du xxème siècle il faut
vivre il faut penser à densément ne
prêtent pas à construire une pince avoir
peu et ne seront jamais mais jamais pour
la danse
ces chaises ses tables ces espaces de
vie n'ont pas pris une ride
l'inspiration charlotte perriand la
puise dans les dernières avancées de son
temps l'automobile les métaux le vers
des formes dynamiques diplômés et déjà
remarqué elle intègre l'atelier de
l'architecte le corbusier à la fin des
années 20 depuis elle refuse de
dissocier architecture et équipements
intérieurs expérience était passionnant
non seulement à cause de le corbusier
mais de tous les jeunes de tous les pays
du monde un 15 jeter a mené un travail
et changer les idées charlotte perriand
cdh équilibre entre l'esthétique et la
fonctionnalité pour chaque création le
corps et son référentiel premier la
hauteur du regard d'un homme
la longueur du bras d'une femme il
suffit de voir son travail sur les
logements de la station de ski des arcs
ou bien sûr des chambres étudiantes
petit espace grand confort
le sujet c'est pas le bâtiment c'est
l'homme qui est de l'or comment va-t-il
vivre derrière tant de génie il y a une
grande humilité
charlotte perriand est longtemps resté
dans l'ombre du corbusier
même quand elle parlait de sa chaise
baptisé lc4 elle sait les initiales de
l'architecte travaille à trois là
corbusier
pourtant charlotte-perriand a cultivé un
style nourrit de son coup de foudre pour
le japon et sa sobriété et de son amour
de la montagne brut est complexe
c'est cette marque qu'elle laisse dans
le monde de l'architecturé du design un
témoignage du xxème siècle qu'elle a
quitté à son crépuscule en 1999
[Musique]